tenemos por aquí un diagrama que se ve
muy interesante veamos si podemos
averiguar algunas cosas acerca de este
diagrama vamos a empezar diciendo que ya
sabemos que la línea m acá esta línea de
aquí
línea m que es paralela a esta otra
línea de aquí la línea n j
la línea m acá es paralela a la línea n
j digamos que sabemos que esta línea es
paralela a esta línea ahora sabiendo eso
y el resto de la información que nos da
este diagrama lo que quiero que hagamos
es que probemos que la medida del ángulo
b o sea el ángulo el mk ok
la medida del ángulo el mk el m acá
queremos probar que la medida de ese
ángulo es igual a la medida del ángulo
aunque la medida del ángulo l nj la
medida del ángulo
n j ahora hay otra forma de describir
esto porque la medida del ángulo lmk lmk
es justo b es b y la medida del ángulo l
nj l nj la medida de este ángulo es a
gay
así es que lo que queremos probar es que
b es igual a a y como siempre te
recomiendo que los intentos por tu
cuenta
ponle pausa al vídeo y luego lo vemos
paso por paso muy bien entonces ahora
vamos paso por paso empezamos viendo el
ángulo l
mk es un ángulo que forma parte de este
triángulo y que sabemos acerca de la
medida de los ángulos de los triángulos
es la suma de las medidas de los ángulos
internos de cualquier triángulo suman
180 grados vamos a escribirlo por aquí
tenemos b que es la medida de este
ángulo más
qué es la medida de este ángulo y
finalmente más 90 grados que es la
medida de este ángulo de aquí aunque hay
entonces aquí tenemos la suma de las
medidas de los tres ángulos interiores
de este triángulo morado y entonces esta
suma tiene que ser igual a 180 grados
como tiene que suceder con cualquier
triángulo y entonces si restamos 90
grados de los dos lados lo que nos queda
es ver más si es igual 180 grados menos
90 grados
esos son 90 grados 90 grados
y bueno si queremos despejar por
completo a b lo único que necesitamos es
restar se de los dos lados y entonces lo
que nos queda es que b es igual a 90
grados menos c
esto está bastante interesante esta
nueva forma de expresar ab y podemos
ahora ponernos a pensar si podemos
escribir de alguna otra forma y por
supuesto si en cualquier momento te
sientes inspirado con la pausa el vídeo
e inténtalo por tu cuenta
bueno entonces podremos escribir de una
forma similar pues a ver observemos el
diagrama yo creo que sí porque por aquí
tenemos este otro triángulo que abarca
casi todo el diagrama pero que se parece
mucho a este triángulo de aquí porque
ahí tenemos este triángulo de aquí
ok tenemos el triángulo l nj y se parece
muchísimo al triángulo lila que teníamos
por aquí el lmk porque este triángulo
grandote morado también tiene un ángulo
recto que es un triángulo rectángulo y
comparten uno de sus ángulos este ángulo
de aquí es el mismo para los dos
triángulos
y me dice y bueno el otro ángulo
interior de este triángulo rectángulo es
el ángulo a así es que como ya sabemos
la suma de las medidas de todos los
ángulos internos de un triángulo mide
180 y es justo lo que vamos a escribir
aquí
ok tenemos que la medida de este ángulo
más
más sé más 90 de este ángulo recto
90 nosotros sabemos que esta suma tiene
que ser igual a 180 grados y que podemos
hacer ahora con esto que tenemos aquí
pues podríamos hacer lo mismo que
hicimos por acá aunque hay tomar 90
grados y restarlo de los dos lados del
igual y luego tomarse y también restarlo
de los dos lados para que nos quede la
azulita entonces lo que vamos a obtener
es a igual
a 180 90 grados
esos son 90 grados menos c y listo a es
igual a 90 grados menos pero pues ve
también es igual a 90 grados menos
entonces esto de aquí también es igual a
b así es que ahora sí podemos decir que
a es igual a b
es igual a b la medida del ángulo lmk y
eso medida es ver es igual a la medida
del ángulo lmj que es